there's a buzz of urgency about the
Parliament as commissioners designates
step up one by one for forensic
cross-examination on their new briefs
yepo contain iron ore patient digital
and Ben amount eundel emo Octans
phonetic late gained fragment eot
digitally Wilton for some the journey
from energy to digital is a journey from
one side of hell to the other mr.
Oettinger seems happy enough though with
the issues confronting him including the
key question of open access to the
internet here is an ALICE tuned as
niemand in the newton listen it's been
our talented mr. Oettinger spoke of the
vital role of the digital revolution in
startups and SMEs of the internet as an
indispensable cultural tool but what of
the blockages out there too in civil
lately with lachine knits it digital
automatische goose toyota if I Britain
digital or vice versa couldn't him I
need attack him I wouldn't survive that
and weld three mother's pavilion ice
rink iron hey Camille and cliff inform
on a bomb builder involvement gift the
Chairman declared himself well enough
satisfied afterwards very intensive very
interesting and questions from both
committees each row and culture are was
very deep over next to Nevin miniature
former deputy prime minister in Croatia
and a diplomat of long standing when
fragile states collapse or when
terrorism expands in Africa it is a
direct threat to Europe when trade flows
increase and business environment
improve it is an opportunity for Europe
as well next year is European year of
development it's also when the UN's
Millennium Development Goals expire and
need replacing next stage for the two
candidate commissioners the vote in
parliament in October or possibly
November next stage for their colleagues
more grilling in Parliament